my name is Mary Katherine Blackwood the  black woods have always lived as house  and we will never leave here no matter  what they say or what they do to us  never  [Music]  father built this gate to keep us safe  but it could not protect him you and  confidence people here believe Constance  killed father none of the true genuine  mysteries of our time there is such a  thing as good taste you ever tasted us  what are you doing  I heard father in his room I feel him  coming back America it's our cousin  Charles black hood he looks just like  father  has he said anything about leaving he is  our cousin and he'll go and he's ready  his presence is a strange new spell we  have many plans to me  [Music]  that chair is my dead brother's chair  I'm going to put death in all their food  and watch them die  he was a very wicked man our Father  the world is full of terrible people  [Music]  you